he was like a brother to me sky Jackson  reacts to the death of her late Jesse  co-star Cameron Boyce so it's very sad  and he was just a happy person so it's  very unfortunate but we're gonna  continue his legacy and I know he would  be proud of us so yeah suicide  [Music]  et spoke with the 17-year old actress at  the premiere of Disney's live-action  re-imagination of The Lion King I'm  super duper excited to be here tonight  it's gonna be amazing  Beyonce's and it which is amazing so I'm  super excited and I think it's gonna be  an amazing film I have not but hopefully  I get to tonight that's like she's like  on my bucket list to me even if I did  rehearse something my head it probably  wouldn't come out  [Music]